a Republican Senator John Thune of South
Dakota is chairman of the Commerce
science and transportation committee
worked to secure Mark Zuckerburg
testimony and met with the Facebook CEO
yesterday senator good morning you met
with him yesterday what did you take
away from that meeting
well good morning John I think that what
I took away from the meeting is that he
wants to take this head-on which I think
he needs to Facebook has to step up take
responsibility for what happened and
tell us what they're going to do in the
future to protect users data and what
they're going to do proactively to stop
the harmful conduct that now they've had
to go back and apologize for because
it's something that happened in the past
we want to see what steps are going to
take going forward but obviously want to
see what he has to say about what's
happened so far and is it more pervasive
than what we initially thought in other
words are there other firms or
businesses out there that have attacked
had access to this data and may have
misused it and based on your
investigation do you believe there are
other firms that have had access to that
data
we don't know for sure about that we've
had briefings at the staff level we've
asked those questions of Facebook we're
waiting for them to get back to us and
mr. Zuckerberg did say yesterday that
they are currently doing that
investigating that looking back at their
relationships and finding out if there
are other firms that that also had
access to data they could have been they
could have been misused does he have to
worry and does Facebook have to worry
about a lot of new regulations from the
federal government I mean in addition to
the specifics of the case here with
Cambridge analytical and some of the
other problems is that the big fear that
Mark Zuckerberg has to worry about well
I think that's I'm sure that's a concern
that they have John and if you look at
some of the the past couple of years you
know we've had hearings on
radicalization on some of these social
media platforms there have been concerns
about political bias and they're in
their news gathering services obviously
the election meddling by the Russians is
another issue so I think all these
things have sort of come to a head and
it's time for Congress to exercise some
oversight will determine after we do
that whether or not there are steps that
need to be taken in the form of
regulation or legislation going forward
but right now we want to get the answers
and we think Facebook needs to be
accountable and
parent and I'm glad that mr. Zuckerberg
is appearing today and this is a rare
issue that has united both sides of the
aisle in Congress with concern does it
surprise you that the president has been
virtually radio silent on this issue you
know I'm not sure that it's in his
domain at the moment I suspect that you
know right now it's sort of a
congressional interest and I think it's
part of our oversight responsibilities
the committee that I chair has oversight
of the Federal Trade Commission which is
responsible for consumer protection and
management of privacy he speaks about
other tech companies like Amazon right
well he does he does seem to have an
interest in Amazon and I think I suspect
at some point that we'll hear from the
President on this issue as well but I
think the whole issue of social media
and its influence in our lives and and
the data they have access to is going to
be an ongoing issue now because more
Americans are concerned about their
privacy and I think they have a reason
to be senator we've already seen
Facebook change its tune on supporting
that it will verify the identity of
political ads and its creators that are
on Facebook however when it comes to
foreign influence in our elections has
facebook done enough what concerns you
well I think Norah that they they're
doing they're gonna he's gonna lay out a
number of steps today that they've taken
since the 2016 election and they are
they're taking a lot of sort of self
pollute policing moves I guess I would
say in terms of trying to root out that
kind of influence and I think their
platforms have become a lot more a lot
cleaner and I think they've got
algorithms now that they can use and
artificial intelligence and different
types of mechanisms to to clean and
clear that up so I think they'll be much
better at it going forward and obviously
this is sort of a wake-up call to them
that they're going to have to senator
who else would you like to hear from in
the coming weeks and months ranking
member Nelson has suggested bringing in
Cambridge analytic Oh would you do that
I I expect at some point we will you
know obviously we're interested in other
firms too that may have had access to
the data in the same way that Cambridge
analytic I did they just announced over
the weekend say Facebook did that
they've suspended yet another firm an
analytics firm and so there are we're
gonna try and get to the bottom of this
and I think it's
entirely likely at some point in the
future that Cambridge analytics and
perhaps other firms may be called in to
to talk about how they got access to
this data how they used it and whether
or not when they were told to they shut
it down I mean some of these firms
violated obviously the user agreements
that they had or the contracts that they
had with Facebook and that too is a big
problem that we need to we need to
address all right senator Thune thanks
so much good luck today